marly ce petit garçon britannique de
trois ans est de retour à la maison
après dix jours d'hospitalisation
il a retrouvé son sourire même si les
médecins redoute que son petit coeur
garde des séquelles de l'inflammation
aiguë dont il a été victime
testés négatifs au qu'ovide 19 il a
pourtant développée selon les médecins
des symptômes similaires fièvre
essoufflement rougeurs des symptômes que
l'on retrouve aussi dans la maladie de
kawasaki qui touchent les jeunes enfants
et peut provoquer une défaillance
cardiaque
mais aujourd'hui ni les pédiatres ni ses
parents ne savent précisément de quoi
souffre r le petit marché
on a vécu un cauchemar d'un cauchemar
parce qu'on a eu très peur et qu'on
retrouve en est très très malade dans ce
contexte on ne sait pas quoi mais depuis
l'épidémie de kovy de 19
les services de réanimation pédiatrique
britanniques ont constaté une
augmentation des admissions d'enfants
avec des symptômes similaires
certains positif au qu'ovide d'autres
négatifs une vingtaine de cas au moins
en quelques jours à peine testo d'asthme
c'est un petit groupe de cas qui est
arrivé en même temps que l'épidémie de
coronavirus qui signifie que ce possible
lien doit être notre principale
préoccupation est ce une alerte a été
lancée au royaume uni comme en france
aussi où une quinzaine d'enfants ont été
hospitalisés à paris notamment ces deux
dernières semaines selon le ministre de
la santé qui n'exclut pas ce matin au
micro de france info un lien avec le
communisme c'est quelque chose que je
prends évidemment vous l'imaginez très
au sérieux je mobilise la communauté
soignante la communauté scientifique en
france et à l'international pour avoir
le maximum de données possibles pour
voir s'il ya lieu de faire un lien entre
le corona virus et cette forme qui
jusqu'ici jusqu'ici n'avait pas été
observé une nulle part des complications
très rare mais qui ont été aussi
rapporté en italie en espagne et en
suisse ces dernières semaines les
médecins précisent toutefois que les
morts d'enfants depuis le début de cette
pandémie sont exceptionnels partout dans
le monde